[Music]
you were just a last-second substitute
for Ellen you hosted the Ellen show I
did this has got to be that was a great
honor but also a huge a huge honor and
one of the best days of my life what
happened is Ellen DeGeneres fell ill I
got called around 11:00 a.m. and they
asked me to go guest host her show which
was incredible and it was again one of
the best days of my life I called my mom
afterwards to tell her all about it I
said and mom and I couldn't believe how
welcoming the audience was you know like
these people came so far to see Ellen
DeGeneres and then I come out and my
mom's like oh I know crust
my mother said this is a huge Ellen
DeGeneres fan yeah but I also kind of
thought she was a huge her own daughter
fan no see when she agreed a little too
readily yes she was like I pity that
crowd I sort of see what she's saying I
mean I think we all kind of do but it
was it was fun and um she's my mom also
said that I read very well you read her
a teleprompter
yeah those were her two words her to or
to praise we can't afford a teleprompter
I don't know what to say right you know
what's funny is Ellen dances on the show
famously that's they and and I'm just
curious is there pressure then for you
to dance if you're though absolutely and
I had to dance just as she does and
she's a very good dancer I am an
enthusiastic dancer I don't dance as
well my technical skills might not be as
good but I had to go through the crowd
like she does and I just kept thinking
everyone is totally smiling and being
polite but they must just be thinking I
wish you were Ellen DeGeneres like I
don't want to be dancing with you if I
was ever in that situation and I don't
think I would ever happen but if they
ever named me that said like we need you
to come over and host Ellen I would
dance the entire hour I think that would
be so funny to start dancing it was a
big oh it's cute it's kind of doing when
Ellen does and I keep doing it kind of
like Ellen and smiling and then I would
keep it up through every commercial
break I would do it for the whole hour
no people would start to get everyone
around you you could see their smiles
turning into he's insane the last act
you're dripping and slap yeah
going and you can see you can see
security trying to stop me to be like
and then we realize yet you just can't
stop I can't stop